العوامل الثلاثون يا استاذ مشاري هي سرطان
سيستمر مع السودانيين على مدى عقود طويله
للاسف الشديد يعني يعني هؤلاء الاسلاميين
همم لعبوا دور سيء في السودان والاكثر من
ذلك انه السودان هو البلد الوحيد الذي شهد
الجريمه الكامله الاسلام السياسي تحديدا
دون اي دوله اخرى طبعا
اي دوله
انقسامات شاهدنا هذا في غزه افغانستان في
الصومال في السودان لانه هو كان متحكم
تماما انقسمين يعني انفصال الجنوب وهل
جريمه كبيره بكل المقاييس هذه جريمه من
جميع
[موسيقى]
طلع الدوله
دمر الجهاز الدوري العام تماما
الوزارات كلها الى جيبهم خاصه
اليوم اليوم
استسلم اصحاب الثلاثين
عامارون هذه الاموال من خلال دول خارجيه
في السوشيال ميديا يعني لما قدم حمدوق
وصار رئيس الوزراء انسان
هم عبر الكتروني وعنده جدا
جدا في انطباعات الاخرين العوامل عامه
الناس
[موسيقى]
فبالتالي همم استثمر في ما قدموه يعني ما
ركبوه من هذه القنوات العامه
[موسيقى]
الوتر الحساس انه ايش الجمله الاخيره
هذه طبعا هم عنده تعبير على مستوى رمزي
يعني بيحاولوا من خلال تنفير الناس من
السيداوي باعتبارها يعني دعوه
[موسيقى]
مع انهم تماما لانه حتى الامم المتحده
بالتفاقياتها عند بنود تجعل لكل دوله
هذه الاشياء هي طبيعتها طبيعه
يعني
للبحث والتفصيل يعني زي اذا تريد القول
انهم اليوم يشتون
في التعبئه ضد شخصياتهم معينه وكل شيء
خليهم يكون المال اليوم داخل السودان هم
اصلا نهبوا اموالهم واخرجوها بالدور
العامه يعني اذا ال- ال- السمين
السودانيون يا استاذ مشاري هم اغنى
الاسلاميين قاطبه لانهم ماذا فعلوا هم
نهبوا جهد العام جعالهم كلهم
همم يعني السودان
في وبعدين كان في شيء اسمه التمكين نعم
يعني في كل اداره يعني انت شيعي انت بعسي
انت
يشيل الطوالي يعني حلال اهلا ولا محل اهل
كفاء